y teme usted que exista una posibilidad
real de guerra total con rusia wild
roses podría haberla esa es la verdad
septiembre de 2021 tras la preocupante
acumulación de fuerzas rusas a lo largo
de la frontera ucraniana a la pasada
primavera el presidente volodymyr de
lenski reconoció la posibilidad de una
guerra en los meses siguientes más
movimientos militares renovarían los
temores de que moscú preparaba una
invasión en noviembre de 2021 ucrania
estimaba que había 90.000 soldados rusos
a lo largo de sus fronteras washington
señaló ejemplos de intervenciones
militares de rusia en el pasado para
advertir que vladimir putin
probablemente estaba planeando una
acción i don't know no sabemos si el
presidente putin ha tomado la decisión
de invadir si sabemos que está poniendo
en marcha la capacidad de hacerlo a
corto plazo aun shourd en febrero para
ejercicios militares con belarús
llegaron más aviones equipos y soldados
rusos a la frontera ucraniana llevando
las estimaciones de tropas a entre 160 y
190 mil a continuación unos extensos
los navales en el mar negro
interrumpieron las rutas marítimas de
ucrania mientras quien culpaba a rusia
de los ciberataques a su ministerio de
defensa y a varios bancos nacionales el
15 de febrero rusia dijo que había
empezado a retirar algunas tropas de la
frontera pero las potencias occidentales
se mantuvieron escépticas el 21 de
febrero putin reconoció las
reivindicaciones separatistas de dónetsk
y luhansk en el este de ucrania y en su
discurso dijo que la ucrania moderna
nunca tuvo una historia de estado
auténtico respect permítanme subrayar
esto de nuevo ucrania no es sólo un país
vecino es una parte integral de nuestra
historia cultura y continuidad
espiritual atrás atrás entonces en lo
que llamó una misión de mantenimiento de
la paz el kremlin envió tropas a las
regiones pero las potencias occidentales
dijeron que constituiría una ocupación
militar eeuu reino unido y sus aliados
respondieron con sanciones a primera
hora del 24 de febrero moscú comenzó a
atacar con misiles y artillería varias
ciudades ucranianas alcanzando objetivos
militares pero también zonas
ahora mientras putin mira hacia atrás en
su legado el hombre de 69 años parece
decidido a finiquitar los asuntos
pendientes es decir el regreso forzado
de ucrania a una antigua república
soviética a la órbita de moscú